i do remember the like the beat that um
like kind of changed your uh like kind
of changed
your life as a producer what oh man
crazy yeah i could say i could say go
crazy but the one that i get the
most accolades from the most
people i would never thought i'd ever
speak to you was canon luanne yeah and
that was
the reason why is like i went acro when
i started traveling bro i was running
into everybody like
premier and all these people and it was
like yo i need to holler at you
and i was like oh yeah like when you
made that beat right
like was your um
like drop like like like did you make
that beat like or did you add that later
like what was the
process of that record with wayne i'm
gonna tell you a story so
so this is how it came about when i uh
when i did go crazy um
a r from atlantic i forgot his name at
the time but he was like yo
i want you to go work with trick daddy
in uh florida no orlando did it no no it
wasn't orlando i was on ireland okay my
phone
was this guy you forget his name but uh
i went to miami and i went to circle
house and
i was busting my brain on what i can
make trick daddy that feel like me
and miami at the same time so
at that time i was like come on ride
this train was like you know
a southern base record and i was like
y'all my east coast to [ __ ] out
and how wanda flipping it um
trick that ain't really like it you know
he was working on a madonna record at
the top
what the [ __ ] yeah it was like tricked
that he was going to strip club every
day from like 11 00 in the morning to
like six and a half
madonna it was i think if madonna was on
a hook or something it was something
that's why
some huge [ __ ] i think trick was huge
huh he was popping
yeah no trick was crazy so my whole
thing was like i love trick as a rapper
i was like damn i just wish he could
come in the room
and be like yo i don't like this but i
like that but it just ain't work out
that way but i wind up
leaving the stuff there but it was a
dude uh fiend that was there
i don't know if you know fiend no limit
yes yeah fiend was just dm'd him today
yeah he was he's a phenomenal writer so
he was like coming in the center
loving everything i was [ __ ] with he
was like bro i love that he was the
first person
to do a canon hook he went on there and
was like i got the a
k i'm with the canon that was it you
didn't know that no i didn't know
that he was the first person to use the
drop it didn't go all the way through
like everybody but he was like yo i got
it a
k with a cannon and i was like oh that's
fire but
it never amounted to nothing so i wound
up taking the record back home
i think i gave it to him first now
yeah you gave it to buster no remember
because orlando gave it to bohegan
bohegan had it first yeah boy you
remember both yeah of course
and then after that it was buster and
then busting tip
buster i don't think bohegan did canon
though i think he rapped on it but he
didn't do the
layout he might not have he didn't have
to be yeah buster did the layout yeah
buster did it buster had it first yeah
he went dumb
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
because there was different iterations
of that record i remember
he went dumb and then uh he wound up
giving to wayne and then
wayne just went stupid the craziest
thing is people don't know is
wayne wrapped the whole beat three
minutes long we had to make the verses
because he just wouldn't stop
so he just he just is in this in the in
the booth he wrapped the whole thing
straight
i still got that version too yeah yeah
so i was going to miami
it was when cali was shooting holler at
me okay and
everybody went to miami for that video
and we were ju
that he dedication i was going to go to
circle house to go pick up
dedicate that's crazy because that's
where the beat was made too but
i was going to circle house to go pick
up the music for dedication too
and um uh it was that same night and
then i went over there and i was like yo
i got this
just beat my man-made like to see if you
[ __ ] with it for the tape and i was the
last song he did
for dedication too and he was spazzed
and like the next day gave it back to me
yeah that was that was the whole making
of that and people don't really know
that story but i tried to tell that
story because that was like
a magical mistake you know when i was
making that record it was like oh
go crazy was the same way when i made it
go crazy
it was for artists we had named willie
the kid oh shout out willie the kid yeah
shout out to willie yep shot the willie
and i think i was making it watching
dead presidents was that y'all's first
artist
yeah okay okay yeah and and i i wind up
um giving it to him and t.i rapped on it
but he didn't i wound up giving willie
another beat because we couldn't get it
right some something happened we
couldn't get that record right for him
so i gave him another beat and then that
went to draw
and you know and that's yeah go crazy uh
is one of those ones man it's like
how crazy was it when you heard jay-z's
remix about to say his first beat out
the gate
holes on the ring it was crazy because
i remember coach k like yo got something
for you
got something for you i'm like man
whatever whatever you talking about
i thought i didn't know what it was
going i thought it was going to be like
a jeezy and a couple other people
that you know and and uh when he said
jay-z i said all right
i'll wait to hear it when i believe it
and to this day uh i think jay-z
performed it at birthday before birthday
bash i forescan in the car yeah and
yeah you know what i mean because i
didn't know what i was doing at the time
we was just you was having fun
yeah i mean it was just everything we
did was fun you know what i mean
damn that's crazy man yeah that record
is like
one of those ones it's like i remember
like
first time i pressed play on that cd
that was the one record
because i'm like a boom bap hip hop head
and that record was like
it was like hearing gz in a different
light yeah that was one thing that i did
strategize i was like yo
cause go crazy original had brick b
drums on it
and i was like how can i get this sound
and him together to make it that and i
always wanted to
sit in front of like him and jay in the
conversations like yo what did you hear
jeezy do
that one made you want to do 64 bars of
classic verse because i you know jay
does a verse he does some special verses
but that one was just long it was
different you know what i'm saying so i
was just trying to figure out like
what did gz say on there that made you
like oh man i gotta go crazy like you
know what i'm saying so
i just i just you know going through
that whole
proc that that whole process was was fun
because
we was just doing us i don't think we i
mean
we had objective to make money but i
think at that time i was just
happy to be a part of facts you know
what i mean yeah for sure